我觉得是这样 我觉得现在是时候吧
现在市场很疯狂 就是涨得有很多
从我们开始来说投资的时候 比方说两年多以前
我觉得大部分一起投的人都是市位以上 至少
然后我觉得现在是一个时候 大家静下来反思一下
然后想一想 接下来市场会怎么走
然后自己的投资怎么去安排
我觉得这个是一个比较重要的时候
然后我没有觉得 就是今天我没有写很多PVD
也没有根据上一个星期怎么样
但是我最近一直在思索这个事情
就是怎么去调整这个仓位
然后怎么去观测这个风险
因为现在当我们来讲 AI是everything
然后我们觉得ALL IN AI的时候
其实没有人去谈这个事情
然后现在的话
你会看到市场上所有人都在说AI
然后大部分人都是半导体专家
就无数的半导体专家
然后我们来去学半导体的时候
可能三年前 然后走了还是比较早
但现在这个市场其实看上去从仓位上来讲
肯定是非常已经有点拥挤
那这种情况下我觉得其实还是要大家想一想
就是我们接下去怎么看这个事
然后我讲几个问题
首先第一个就不能去做空
你即使是看空这个市场
如果你认为它是有问题的
然后你去做空
你很有可能去空2007年
大部分做空人其实都没有活到08年09年出问题
如果说07年的话
其实大部分都没有活到
如果说想去压住对冲或者是想去压住做空
你就必须要去找一个钢杆极高
然后风险就是面临大跌钢杆极高的这么一个产品
这个我们到时候再去讨论
我讲一下市场上现在我感觉到的四个风险点
然后这个四个风险点
互相之间其实都是有影响
我会写一篇比较长的文章放给大家
然后这四个风险点之间
最后它其实是有一个
我感觉是有个罩门的
就是它有一个密门在那里
你如果动不了那个点
整个市场其实都是动不了
第一个我觉得
先说一下市场现在运行的一个基本的状态
现在市场基本运行的一个状态
就是认为我们底层的两红是OpenR和Fopic
他们的业绩增长够快
然后在增长够快的情况下
是能够达到现在市场中间的一层
那几个hyperscale
他们做的capacity的投入
这个事情是能够完成的
所以这个是市场的真正的主线
你要去动到这条主线
就是动到了市场的密脉
任何一个不在这条主线上的所有的分支的问题
全通通不是问题
这就是我们今天讲的第一个问题
就是说市场最大的第一个
就是市场有一个金钟罩
有一个极强的铜墙铁壁
你在任何负面信息的打击下
其实都打击不到它
包括我们一直在看多
就是我们也相信的这条主线的命脉的
就是最终的AI的业绩增长
或者是RAM有增长
它会超过hyperscale的投入
也不是说超过投入吧
至少让你这个投入可以justifying这个投入
我们一直是相信这个事情的
所以这个铜墙铁壁意味着
我们当时在最早的时候
包括SIBB出问题
然后到后来关税战
然后到伊朗危机
然后到比方说CMCTA卖出
中间来来回回
包括在技术上的各种各样问题
24年的时候有过
英伟达的液冷出问题的那个
那个时候Blackwell的液冷出问题
然后最近英伟达的可能是
有他那个交换机可能过热
然后接着有可能CPU会
就是那个光学的东西
可能会delay
会那个延后有各种这些事情
但这些事情都无所谓
因为他没有伤掉这条命脉的主线
也就是AI还是就是会很强
他的也驱动的需求很大
我们如果说哪怕我明天说
当然没有了
哪怕明天说飞门delay了
那个英伟达NB的卡delay了
你就是延后了
CAPA Scala可能不太会去愿意去投入
不通道的这个算力
就是他需要每一代都是能够算力提高几倍
然后他可能会延后一下这个投入
对市场可能是一个短期的这个往下杀
但是不会影响到他的这个命脉
这个命脉就是我们现在所有的
从微观来看每一个公司都是真实的
每一个缺货也都是真实的
需求也是真实
业绩也是真实
就是说很强
你这个很强
最后的真正的命脉就是我刚刚讲的
你的模型的增长要能够justify capex
capex带动的所有半导体的收入和盈利
半导体的缺货
每一个缺货都是真的
所以我为什么把它列成第一个风险
就是当你认为所有东西都是没有任何
就是像通墙铁壁一样
然后挡住了所有的风险
这些风险其实在漫画都还是存在的
你比较说油价的问题
那个包括说利率的问题
包括说可能你QE
那个你通胀上升以后
你不管是要做QT
或者是兼缓降息的问题
那这些所有的负面信息
对市场冲击是远远不及正面信息的
在过去一年游胜
24年的时候
你们可以回顾一下
24年6月份
好像3月份
3月份9月份
两次通胀的数据偏高
然后市场还是震动了一下
现在这些数据已经没有办法
震动这市场
因为从底层来看
每一个公司确实是真实
所以市场上所有的投资人
包括我接触的对冲基金
包括各种各样的
甚至KOL对冲基金
他们都会专到一个细分的资产
包括存储啊光啊
然后会专到细分的一个公司
从越是细分
你看下去越是真实
它的缺货就是真的
订单都是真的
然后产能也不足
产能再提升还是需要时间
还能涨价
一切都是真实
但你要拔到更高来看
它可能会
我后面讲
可能会要有风险
然后这是一个最大问题
然后我说一个总结性的话
就是PEDPE的抛磨
不代表它不是抛磨
DPE的抛磨
只是让你看到每个公司
引力很好
让你在每一次下条的时候
都勇敢的冲进去
然后加杠杆
我看得到
韩国大规模的在
在新海利市上面加杠杆
韩国人
韩国人现在有的
原来搞币圈的社群
都已经把那个社区
五倍杠杆的海利市
然后五倍杠杆
听说是五倍杠杆的海利市
还有抵押自己房子的
就是非常凶悶
那个GC09在香港
已经前几名的ETF了
就两倍杠杆的海利市
然后那个整个存储上面的仓位
非常非常早
但是没关系
因为它需求很大
它真实的会有那个引力
所以它还在涨
这个其实是最危险
就是最危险的
就是在于
包括高杠杆
也是一个很大的
就是也是很大的
我们叫门外的野蛮人
因为你高杠杆随时会帮我
但是每一次下跌
低批议
导致你敢去不停的去投进去
这个有个不恰当的比喻
就是高息懒存的
皮图皮
它每天都给你挣反会
每天都给你利息
我们每天都看到业绩在增加
每天股票在涨
然后每天业绩增加
每天在缺货
每天在涨价
现在华强北
就今天过去三天了
把Ned的价钱涨了5%
然后前一周又涨了5%
所以你说每一个缺货是不是真实
我就追些细节的东西
确实都是真实的
还有就是我昨天听说的
Waver说那个光照一次Waver
涨价一倍吗
在国内
就是境外的金援厂已经没有能力
就没有compatibility
没有产能
去做很多的那个假供了
代价供了
然后把这个客户都踢出来
包括TSMC
包括Global房主员
就是低端制程
低端制程都已经没有出路
不帮你留了
所以回到国内还不成熟的制程
国内原来25块钱美元
我昨天听到
然后现在涨到50块钱美元
翻了一倍
原来追感性的金援厂不赚钱
亏钱
现在都有可能要赚钱
这个就是
这个就是现在市场半脑抵达求后
因为你看到它下面
美国都很真实
然后我现在应该透露
我对于金援厂都是应该透露
那么只要你的底层是不出问题的
你所有的逻辑都是没有问题
但DPE的泡沫它的风险是
你们见过P2P怎么报的
就是它如果出问题的时候
你逃都来不及逃
因为你的P是一个幻想
就有句话叫什么
凡有所向皆是虚
你一旦这个幻象被打破的时候
就很恐怖
胖下面
那么这幻象会不会被打破
那么待会说
我觉得现在没有到一定的程度
但是是绝对值得提起100倍的注意的
这是第一个问题
然后第二个问题是流动性洪水套天
我讲的风险全部是当下的利好
流动性洪水套天
我们之前讲过ESLR
然后ESLR是等于是一次性的
把流动性都给你放出来
如果你回过去看过去QE的过程
从2008年开始QE
基本上我们Regularity Regulation
在2012年14年左右完成了
在这个2008年到2014年之间
一直在搞QE
然后搞了这一段时间的QE
其实对应的是市场的区放感
本身在2008年之前
金融市场刚刚过高
然后监管比较少
然后到后来开始监管
刚刚在金融层面降下来
但是在央行资产负担表上面就提升
就等于我赢了更多钱
你刚刚少一点
这个QE的效果就是
你可以基本上滑到后面的
就是金融区放感
那么后面经济差
它又搞过QE
当然也搞过QT
来来回回很多次
疫情的时候又持续性的搞过好多时间
QE一个月大概1200亿
那是疫情的时候的QE
像是放了水龙头
一条水给你留给你
一条河流出来
因为它每个月再给你1200亿
相当于一条河流到一个池塘
把这个池塘水给进满了
地上全是水
所以这个是疫情的时候
现在是把bug放开
当时做了几年的QE
对应的deregulation去监管
对应的加监管
现在置换成今天的deregulation去监管
然后一下子把钱给你放出来
所以在4月份的时候
我们之前去年就讲4月份
去年6月份就讲
4月份流动性放出来很多
所以这个流动性会翻来
会让市场暴涨就是大水漫灌
它像是开闸放水
一下子把水给你冲过来
但是我一直觉得流动性这种东西
适合多巴胺很像
就是你需要持续的获得快乐
但是多巴胺它其实不是一个奖励因子
多巴胺是一个期待因子
什么叫期待因子
就是我抽了一口液
我很爽以后
我过一会要再抽
要抽更多
我才能够获得同样的快感
就是你的流动性也是一样
你以流动性大规模进来以后
狂欢要持续狂欢
你要维持这个预期值
哪来的钱维持这个预期值呢
你现在一下子放了4万多亿
银行可购买国债
就4万5千亿
银行可购买的资产出来
流动性非常宽愈
包括我们看到银行间的流动性
sulfurate
sulfurate是很低
然后bank reserve很高
sulfurate一直低于基准
低于OS swap
然后好几天了吧
就包括上周你现在发债
其实流动性还剩快
相对来说还是比较宽愈
那么这个过程其实是会慢慢影响力
就是它的对市场对它的反应
对它的那个快感
是会慢慢减退的
往后看是一个减退的过程
你不可能再把再把那个
这个就是关
就是什么
那个capital requirement
就是那个资本金要求
你不可能再减了
所以这个我觉得是
我们现在看下来的第二个问题
然后第三个问题
就是上面这些人在群摸乱舞
我们说半导体吧
我一直讲半导体车行业
半导体这个行业呢
让我感觉过去是黑社会扬言
说不好听是黑社会扬言
就是它其实非常垄断
是个卖当市场
然后完全的计划经济
就是你的需求是多少
从光刻机开始能产能多少
然后到光刻机到了台积电
台积电产能是多少
台积电产能给到谁
然后谁能够在我这里
有多少篇
我现成怎么分
然后签每年就分蛋糕
台积电就每年分蛋糕
然后这其实继续维持在
那么你是我大哥的这个资助房苹果
那你就拿最先进的信程
然后三大米出来
我就先给你苹果了
然后苹果你用了六个月
我给高通和高给media take
对吧
然后这个是一个秩序型
但是这适用于原来的消费电子
因为每一个环节
它其实没有经历过AI
AI带动的并行计算
对于半导体的巨大需求
然后这个巨大需求带动
就像于一辆老车往前
猛开
猛开的时候
它不光是这个鼓露出问题
它可能发动机
不光是发动机出问题
它鼓露也出问题
都可能它扎车片有问题
就整一个系统没有经过这样量产的需求
那么在这个每一个量产需求的时候
发现到处都是拼紧
所以我们年初的时候也讲过嘛
就是整个半导体
我们叫做every dog has its time
每一个都会出头日
因为每一个它都缺货
每个都出头日
所以过去你可以这么想
这个台积电是五亿碳涨雷诺
它收了保护费以后分给所有人
现在每个黑社会都可以过来给你收回钱
你成熟也可以涨
明天MLCC也可以涨
淘词片也能涨
然后再涨下去
CPU也可以涨
对吧
CPU也涨了
接着光幕化也可以涨
光幕化Lumantem还没给你涨价呢
Lumantem手上产能是完全是靠产能的公司
还没给你涨价呢
因为我可以给你涨价对吧
你台积电都涨了
涨了Wafer都涨了10%了
那我GlobalFoundry为什么不能涨
我的GFS也可以涨
GFS已经准备涨价
就是包括因为GFS和那个刚刚讲
这个TSMC他们把那个客户给推出来
导致很多客户都已经跑到中国
中国光照一次
25块钱到50块钱
你想DUV的进行落后现成光照60次
3000块钱
一张微粉
所以这个是就是一个我们叫做
不叫群魔乱
我叫群雄病棋的时代
屏群雄病棋代表着秩序其实被打破了
回到我们刚刚讲的这个命脉的问题
就是命脉是你要能够预期到
我的KAPEX投入
是可以对应于你的业绩增长
就是你的那个收入增加
这个Antopic Open Eye的收入增加
这两件事情可以在可见的未来
比如28年或29年
你得高我一个时间
我有这个预期
它能够追得上
不是说数字完全追得上
至少两个说你KAPEX一万五千亿
然后我的盈利是三千亿五千亿
那这个是追得上的吗
因为你的换卡的周期
是你的投入卡的盈利
像Allocore预期是一年半到两年
然后我一年半到两年
收回我的卡的成本
后面的这个卡才是继续于热
能够赚钱
你要把这个商业就是钱的模式
我们今天在所有在
包括在推特上
包括在国内在讲半导体的
都是分成两类人
只要跟半导体相关
然后有一点技术背景
或者他觉得有演技术背景
他讲的都是半导体和Token的事情
没有人讲钱的问题
就是这个才是你命脉
如果说你对于KAPEX的投入的效果
你一计瓦的投入的金额是不可控的
你就会影响这个预期
这个是真正中心的命脉
你是不能够动它的
一旦把这个预期给打破
市场其实是要搬掉的
你存储今天在华强被涨
因为存储这个市场
其实是这样
它有点像当时铁矿石
因为它是个商品
DDR肯定是个商品
包括Ned都是个商品
你商品的交易价
交易额是很小很小的
然后但是商品的签约额是很大的
就是B和PTOP跟中国人签个协议
他去卖了很多铁矿石
但是外面有个很小很小的交易市场
在那里每天交远
然后把市场价格炒了很高
炒高以后
他给你谈协议
把你谈高了
所以它是一个商品
是这么一个逻辑
你把它想成铁矿石公司就可以了
但是你现在的现货一直在涨
你连Ned不是内存是存储
存储都给你能够每个星期
每个星期到5%到10%的时候水平在涨
所以你最后一方面会消费到
伤害到消费电子
会伤害到碳级消费
我们的人是碳级消费
你也会影响到
你真正规及消费的最终的那条主线
就是你的CAPEX是要contain
就CAPEX和收入预期是要维持一样的
多说一句消费的问题
现在都在讲一个问题了
叫做消费
就是碳级消费
而规及消费
取代碳级消费
包括你先看到消费电子这么疲软
你手机也卖不动了
然后但是问题说
你手机的配件都在涨
因为在规及消费那里
他能够拿到70%的毛利率
然后能够
能够因为有70%毛利率
所以他把碳级消费给挤退掉了
但我回来要说一句话
所有的消费都是碳级消费
就是你最终的消费都是人
人在消费导致软件公司有需求
软件公司去花了这个头盆
然后才去你这边买了算力中心
算力中心才去做CAPEX
然后再去买半导体
不存在最终的规计消费
这个东西是不存在的
规计的调用确实起了很大很大量
就像我们当年起云的时候一样
云当时刚出来的时候
大家用云也是没感觉
就是用很多
后来不都也控制了吗
很多公司也都控制了
所以不太存在
最终完全脱离碳级的消费
这个是个维密体
它只是在一个中间过程量
需要大量的规计调用
使得这个消费才改变
然后去改变碳级的支出
这个是有的
举个例子
我们很多的人要失业
我觉得最终AR会捲掉
几亿人的工作
这是必然会发生的
因为它不发生
你的整个肌膜泡沫的权要垮掉
是这么一个情况
然后这个是我刚刚讲第三个
就是群雄逐鹿
那第四个就回到我们刚刚讲的主线
就是主线的溶错级差
我们今天在CAPEX
justifiableCAPEX
可以被justified
可以被认证的投入
对应于我的收入可认证的投入
一条非常窄的钢丝上面条
也就是说市场预期
anthropic的收入会不停地增加
急速的增加
open eye也会增加
然后因为它增速够快
所以到时我们能够
把两件事情合在一起
这个其实背后是说
我们需求的token是在指数级的上升
半导体的生产力在现实上
你不管怎么扩产
你都是现行的
你直接不上指数
所以你永远缺乎
对的 没错
然后token的需求是不会有回调的
就是它连波动都不会
因为它是直线上升
这个也是我之前在两年前就说的
token需求是指数级的
然后这个市场半导体
要被推到天上去
那确实都已经发生了
但是我不是说现在去做封塔
只是我们是值得
因为你们收入
你们帐户都已经识位了
你有足够的必要在现在这个时候
反思一下这件事情
就是第一个
它的需求曲线是完全一条指数韩数
韩数会回调的
第二个
它的这个需求曲线和
它的需求曲线跟质量是不是有关
就是你在回顾软件的时候
一个软件淡繁出来
它很好用
包括打个游戏很好玩
所以你们都会去安装
你就会按照软件的思维去考虑
但AI并不是这样的
AI是你最后要调用这些资源去做infra
相当于是一个工厂
我给工厂下来订单
因为好用
所以我工厂下订单
工厂挤压了以后
它给我的质量就粗之烂糟的
这件事情已经发生了
所以市场有没有定价关于
我如果我的需求在
如果我的需求在增加了很大的时候
因为供应不足
会导致我质量下降没有
导致我质量下降以后
我的需求会不会减弱
会不会变
变缓
至少我增速会不会变缓
也没有定价
所以这个才是真正的问题
就是我其实不太关心说
每一个公司
现在因为
如果说我们当时3月底的时候去买的股票
买了半导体
这些买哪张都无所谓
我现在回国
我们当时是买了AMD
对吧
然后我们大规模参为买了AMD
但你回过头来看
你买AMD或者是你去买了
Cocon这么烂的公司
也不是说这么烂吧
但至少Cocon它没有产品
ARM也没有产品
就是你半导体里面
你买的哪张都是一样的
因为everything has its time
然后你在光里面
你买了AOI掌握
你买的乱腾也掌握
就是基本上就是都是一样
需求这方向都是一样
这条需求曲线不变
他们还要掌握
包括AOI和乱腾
还是要掌握
你没差
因为你看不到镜头的需求
特别是光
特别是光看不到镜头
而且光比存主跟那个
光只是不涨价
但它完全是根据你的那个
供应来定价
那么你回过头来
只是说这条钢丝会不会
我说的就是这条钢丝
你会不会有预期的变化
市场能不能忍受你这个预期的变化
在过去其实经常是有的
也就是你一个模型
比方说我们举个例子
去年年底的时候就发生这个事情
OpenAI当时出的模型没有
其实OpenAI的模型
被全本来给超越了
就是而且是左手替右手了
他都不是预参加
他都不是说我OpenAI
被那么Kimi超越对吧
他时当时OpenAI被全本来超越
所以导致市场对于OpenAI
给到Oracle的Background的订单
不认章给Oracle的那个
给Oracle的那个CDS
打到500多个点
所以Oracle跌到今天还没反弹
现在OpenAI又起色
因为现在变老大了
这模型最好用
这些跟着它又恢复了
都还没有涨回当时Oracle
就像Oracle都还没涨回当时Oracle
对了
那你回过来说
你可以想象到市场对于这个的容错
有多差
包括你回顾每一次
那个尼伟达的比方说有delay
或传出他有什么这个技术的问题
或者任何一家有什么技术问题
你看这市场就主线的技术问题
市场有多么的脆弱
就是你动到任何下面相关的东西
它都非常非常脆弱
那为什么我们过去出一点问题
是能够能够扛过来的
因为中间这几家真正相信AI的
是中间这五
这个S模不应该写
这是AI化的话算不上
这中间应该是Oracle
这五个hyper scale
是真正好像还少了一个
少了一个
那你对我来说少了
Google Microsoft的Amazon
对 这也amazon没写
就是真正相信AI的
是hyper scale
Google Amazon Microsoft
Meta和Oracle是他们
所以一旦当时模型比方说有问题
Oracle可以说我继续投入
我借债继续投入
我发股票继续投入
因为我相信AI肯定跑出来
所以当今年Anthropic的收入开始暴涨
接着现在OpenAI的收入开始要暴涨
OpenAI收入真的很快
所以当时投入的人都获得了
讲啥就get a reward
但是明年这些hyper scale
是没有钱去透露的
今年的Tabax到770个别人
就7700亿
7700亿到7500亿
然后你的free cash flow已经变富的
你一定要借债
明年搞到1万亿
明年你搞到1万亿的基础是
这两家的收入可以暴涨
继续暴涨
让市场认可
觉得你可以这样增长
然后任何你前面的故事
但是对于你这个故事的容错
会变得更低
这就是我们讲的
刚四期五的问题
然后还有一个
就是我最后要讲的
它的命门在这三家
后面还有一个结盟栏
三个预算家
其实最主要的在Anthropic的头上
因为今年涨的石头是在最猛
Anthropic的石头绝对是最猛的
然后现在551
就是5月中传出来的数据551
你想他去年的时候给的数据是90亿
90亿就今年年底
预期90亿100亿
然后去年在12月份好像还是在90亿
然后到了现在已经做到551了
预期今年年底
在今年二三月份的时候
预期今年年底是300亿
现在已经做到551了
所以真正的领头的是它
就是我们在说AI这次如果要调整
你得像打仗一样
你要把人家主帅给震斩
对吧
震斩哪个效果最好
震斩它
为什么
它现在模型几乱
就是如果你实际用过
那个Cloud的模型的话
Cloud的模型化
因为调用太多
以至于它的模型质量
下降很厉害
Token质量下降很厉害
说句不夸张的话
Anthropic现在的模型
使用的效果没有KIMI
就在编程上不录KIMI
然后更不要说解决后绑员了
Mobile AI可能比较好
很多
它以前曾经在二三月份的时候
是非常强
我自己写代码
我们自己写的代码
然后我们自己写代码的话
在我用GPT去
OLED我过去写的那个代码
在二三月份几乎是完美无暇
然后后面就开始出错
现在写的代码每段都出错
就不是每一段
就每个模块都会出错
而且会出几个很严重的错
所以它现在为什么
还就是个Token需求
Token需求增长还是这么快呢
因为Anthropic
你讲讲我自己为例
因为我出错
所以我来回不停地调用
所以我其实用了Token更多
只是我们又达到这个效果
效果更差
让我很不满意
但是效果更差
很不满意
它会不会转化成需求减弱
这件事情是事实上要去考虑的
我觉得是会的
而且它会的
就Anthropic需求减弱
它不要说增速变平
它只要增速就加速度开始变低
就足够让市场喝一壶的了
市场就要吓死了
因为你会看得到
真正你支撑你的军心
讲Anthropic AI这个东西是个婴儿
从它婴儿刚开始出来
第一天大家相信它
给它喂奶
喂奶的是那个hyperscale
你奶妈的奶又喝完了
你用哪来的钱
昨天我讲到这个问题
跟一个朋友讲到
朋友就是一个对冲基金的朋友说的
就是说你讲的所有的问题
都可以用一句话解决
就是增加半导体投入
只要半导体数量够多
你的问题全部会被解决
我说你讲的是没有问题
对的
但是钱谁出钱
华尔街会认证和账吗
就是你告诉我投入半导体
继续开盘子
一万亿不够
再投一万五千亿
然后你的模型会变得更好更聪明
然后你觉得市场会不会暴跌
这必然要暴跌
问题还有一个
原来是预算加在B
现在anthropic
你至少用的状态
你还不如中国模型
会出来一个词
叫做模型商品化
这个词已经被Larry说出来了
就是你回去看一下3月份吧
3月初吧
那个Oracle CEO做一个访谈
说谈到这个问题
就叫商品化
叫做那个模型商品化
它的本来的意思是说
模型训练到最后
你的编辑效益在下降
然后模型最后靠的是什么
一个是靠我Oracle的算力
第二个靠我Oracle那么多数据
所以我很牛
这是它的本质
但是确实没有错
模型商品化
那我就会问一个问题
你花那么多钱去做训练干吗
去做训练干吗
中国的模型公司直接把你征留了
然后他们成本比你低
十分之一的成本在那里做info
然后我用下的效果
我没有你比你跟你差不多
那为什么我要给你这么多钱
让你anthropic open AI
然后去做这么多的训练和算力呢
其实模型本身是一个梦
就是你如果给它一个简单直白的
半导体到生产力
这个东西是没有办法
这么快的转起来的
它中间需要一个梦
这个梦就是我的模型
我的模型更好
我模型每一代更新的更好
所以我真正生产
我之前自己也讲过这话
真正生产
我肯定用anthropic open AI
我不可能用中国模型
因为它的质量更好
出了一个问题
不出问题
比你出一堆问题有用的多
但是我确实也没有考虑过这个事情
就是当你的需求变大的时候
你的质量下降
你质量下降
市场就会提我们叫做模型商业
模型商品化
你的梦就会被打碎
你的你真正的最最底座的这个梦
要被打碎
这个影响的不光是美国
中国半导体都一样
就是这个一岁全岁的
但我相信
因为确实模型差距是很大的
最终的形态
它都是会长回来
只是你不管怎么跌都会长回来
而且半导体
在现在这个牛市里面
获得了开始获得更多的资金
他们投入
然后出产能
在今天才发生
过去几年的问题
是因为这帮半导体的人
根本就不相信AI
所以他没投入
你积累到今天
积重反反
他这个长的石头很
因为缺货很厉害
最终的模式
我我点评一个吧
我觉得AI是一个集中权利的
而不是分散权利的
也就是不恰当的比喻
在文革的时候
发你红宝书
让你去造反冲示委大院
结果不是为了给你权利
而是为了把权利更集中
在AI里面也是一样
就是你获得模型
最终获得模型和算力和智慧的人
模型就是智慧
是集中的
比方说大公司
比方说集中的政府
有更强的支付能力
我今天能够做很多的交易
因为我之前用了Cloud
用了AI使我的很多的程序
跟Jump和Gain Street
处于一个水平
但是以后他们才能够支付
更多的投坑的费用
他们愿意付100万兆一个人
100万美元兆一个人
他可以付500万用AI
把几个人给砍掉
我付不起
所以真正的最后的智慧
会落入到更加集中的人手上
就这个才是以后的
反正以后下一轮的有失
下一轮有失的
有考虑问题
这一轮现在如果要看
是不是什么时候会调整
或者要出风险
我们就要去集中的去关注
这两个公司的收入
因为我耳机看不懂模型
好不好
他们也不用
他们也不用来编程
大部分99的人也不用他来做
就非常重的火
像我们现在就是做的事情
是要结果可验证
下单速度多少
怎么样
这个马上就结果可验证
没有做这样的事情
那就是你要一方面
做这样的事情
人家告诉你
他的质量是不好了
那你就要去关注
他的收入增速会不会变慢
每个月越中
观测他的收入增速会不会变慢
但不要去做空
就是做空成危险的
因为你整个需求
每一个你细致越到底层
越到公司层面
或者到行业层面
你看得越是乐观
你觉得都是很乐观
但是我觉得现在是一个什么时候
抓了很多钱
那你就往上拔上来
在更高的层面去看看这件事情
然后再决定一下自己的策略
好吧
今天我讲的时间不要长
然后我会写一篇长一点的文章
发给大家
然后你们到时候可以看一看
那我就今天不做Q&A了
谢谢大家